[Music]
for the daily cancellation today i must
sadly cancel many of you in the audience
for your involvement
in a totally disgraceful and
disappointing display over the weekend
it all began when rumors started
circulating online
that president biden tragically pooped
his pants while visiting with the pope
in rome amy tarkanian a political
strategist and pundit was one of the
first to make this odorous allegation
tweeting quote
the word around rome is that biden's
meeting with the pope was unusually long
because biden had a bit of a bathroom
accident at the vatican and it had to be
addressed prior to him leaving i know we
joke often about this but this is the
actual rumor going around rome now
next thing you know
hashtags like hashtag poopgate and
hashtag poopypantsbiden and the more
direct hashtag bidenshpants were
trending nationwide on twitter
other sources were you know chiming in
all claiming that yes joe biden did
indeed drop a steamy load in his pants
right in front of pope francis
and then millions of other people
with no special knowledge about the
situation people with no specific
insights into joe biden's defecation
habits at all frankly
still were posting about the subject
spreading this insidious rumor
and to once again clarify by insidious
rumor i am referring to the claim that
joe biden pooped himself at the vatican
that's the rumor
and personally i'm outraged and
disgusted by all this
it is the absolute height of your
responsibility to spread rumors of this
sort
there is no legitimate reason to call
attention to the issue of joe biden
[ __ ] himself no reason
someone has to be the mature one in this
situation and as usual that job has
fallen to me which is why i am not
talking about the subject of joe biden
soiling himself
i would never talk about something so
crass and objectionable and
unsubstantiated we don't even know if
joe biden really did poop his pants
there are some people saying he pooped
his pants others sang that he didn't
poop his pants
still there are others saying that we
have no idea what joe biden did or
didn't do in his pants
in the face of this uncertainty
the dignified and honest thing is to say
nothing at all
i am therefore begging all of you to not
talk about this
and if you didn't know about it until
you just heard about it right now
don't talk about it
it's not the kind of thing we should be
discussing which is why i have
personally chosen to do my part by not
calling attention to it at all it's
better if the public never even hears
about this rumor
the rumor that joe biden president
united states pooped himself so please
once again
just don't talk about it in fact shortly
before we went on air i noticed another
hashtag associated with the poopypants
predicament a large number of social
media users have apparently caused the
hashtag shartweek to trend
this is not only potential
misinformation but also makes light of
the trauma suffered by actual shark
attack victims
and actual shark attack victims that's
why i would never extend this pun by
saying that the vatican became something
of a shark tank when biden arrived
that's a joke i'm not going to make
there are many other presidential poop
jokes that
i will not make
and would be very angry to hear anyone
make for example i'm not gonna say that
through his eight years as vice
president biden apparently got
accustomed to being the number two guy
in the white house i'm not gonna say i'm
not gonna say that biden flew back from
rome in air force two i'm not gonna say
that involuntary defecation must be a
hereditary problem for biden since it
runs in his genes
these would be vulgar and unfunny jokes
and i'm not going to make them or any
other because there's nothing funny
about a turd
especially a turd in the pants of the
president
allegedly
now all we know for sure
the only thing we should be saying about
biden's visit with the pope
is that he went there in his official
capacity as a president united states
and he did his duty
that's it
outside of that our responsibility is to
comport ourselves with maturity and
dignity and respect the office of the
presidency and we should still respect
the office even if that man in that
office happens to have evacuated his
bowels right into his underwear
you know i don't care if biden did have
a literal holy moment in front of the
pope that doesn't change anything
except his diaper
as for the rest of us we have to be
adults about this
and the fact is that many of you have
failed in that regard you have used
biden's poo filled pants as a forum for
jokes and mockery rather than gazing
upon them in solemn silence as is your
duty and his apparently a legend
and for that
all of you today are canceled
shame on you
shame on you
listen hit that subscribe button right
now do it right now i thank you for your
compliance it is
somewhat appreciated